خلال مقابله تلفزيونيه اعتبر الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان حلف الشمال
الاطلسي يشارك في الحرب باوكرانيا من خلال
امداد كييف بالاسلحه ان دول الناتو ترسل
عشرات مليارات الدولارات من الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا هذه مشاركه فعليه في النزاع ولو
بصوره غير مباشره في جرائم نظام
الغربيه هدفا واحدا وهو تدمير الاتحاد
السوفياتي السابق والجزء الرئيسي منه
روسيا الاتحاديه
خلال هذه المقابله جدد بوتين دعوته الى
قيام عالم متعدد الاقطاب ولا عالم يبنى
فقط من اجل مصلحه واشنطن على حد تعبيره ما
يفسر التقارب الصيني الروسي تقارب يزعج
الدول الغربيه وعلى راسها واشنطن التي
اتهمت مرارا بيكين بتزويد روسيا باسلحه
لدعمها في النزاع
نحن مقتنعون بان القاده الصينيين يخططون
لارسال معدات فتاك الى روسيا لكن لم نلاحظ
انه جرت اتخاذ قرار النهائي ولم نلاحظ
ادله على انهم سلموا اسلحه لروسيا
تعتقد واشنطن بان تزود موسكو بمعدات غير
فتاكه عبر شركات صينيه من جهه حذر مستشار
الامن القومي
من عواقب مثل هذه الامدادات بحسب معلومات
فستكون هذه المعدات عباره عن طائرات بدون
طيار وذخيره على وجه